US now to discuss,
David Gergen,
CNN senior political analyst,
former adviser to Presidents
Nixon, Ford, Reagan and Clinton.
Good to see you as always, David.
If we pick up with those comments
from former Maryland Governor
Larry Hogan,
you also had former Arkansas Governor Asa
Hutchinson saying, look,
I think Larry Hogan the star,
but I think more voices are really
where it's at in terms of the party.
Larry Hogan said,
elect that office
isn't the only way to make a difference.
There's a frustration
about the divisive politics
in this country at this point.
And yet the loudest, most extreme voices
do continue to dominate.
Do you see a scenario
where that changes at all
We'll have to wait to hear,
but it's good to be here this morning.
And I must tell you that
I think
increasingly the this has become a too
personal race.
There's Trump and there's dissenters.
And then there's everybody else
in the Republican side
and no one in that everybody else,
I think, has a chance to
really advance
until DeSantis has been has been
checked out.
You know, the press,
as we know all about Donald Trump
more than we want to know
in some cases,
But but DeSantis has not gone
through that kind of screening.
And the press
the press will be doing that
in the next few weeks
because there's so obviously
a Trump versus dissenters race right now.
And well, from that, we'll know.
Does anybody else have a chance?
And right now,
I would say that
nobody else is in the running
as I say, there are dissenters.
There's Trump
and then there's a whole stream
of other people coming on.
But look at the judge.
I'm sure that would
we respond to this Look at Mike Pompeo.
You know,
one would think that he is a heavyweight
with the party
and he's not showing up anywhere.
And then he didn't
he was not speaking at C-PAC.
The best I can tell.
And I don't think he
had an invitation there.
David Gergen,
I would
never debate you on political history
or if I did, I would be very bright,
but I would do it anyway.
Now, I'm just going to ask a question.
Okay.
If we look at the last several
presidential cycles,
the frontrunner
or frontrunners
at this stage, of the race
almost always flame out.
I mean, go back to 2008.
McCain was dead in the water,
going nowhere.
I mean,
Obama was considered a longshot,
then came through
You know, you go to 20, 16,
of course, people
eliminated Trump as a candidate.
Biden, you know, was really
didn't have a chance
until South Carolina in the 20, 20 cycle.
Right.
What does history tell us
about frontrunners
at this stage of the race
and why why do you think that this one
those frontrunners are
likely to stay frontrunners
Well I think Trump is
likely to stay a frontrunner
because you know he's he's
taken out a lot of hits
and there he is
still standing you the CPAC is still his
you know there's no
the fire and brimstone
that we associate with the Packers
has gone out
a lot and Trump's fire has gone out a lot
but he's still out there.
On the other hand,
DeSantis has not is I think a more
if anybody's going to go, go, go down,
it may be to DeSantis,
you know,
typically when these new faces come on,
some of them peak very early,
I would suggest.
And then they after some initial view,
they're going to do really very well.
They they fade and new people
come to the fore
and Obama
comes to the fore out of nowhere.
And when Biden came back,
he was a known figure,
but he was more durable
because he was such an unknown figure.
We don't know yet
whether DeSantis is durable
as a candidate.
He's got he's clearly very shrewd,
very interesting, very bright guy.
On the other hand,
you know,
a lot of the early reporting suggests
he can be very mean.
You can be
you know, he can be very tough on people,
not very pleasant underneath all this.
So let's wait and see, Jim,
how that all sort of worked out.
There's dissenters
where well,
you know, the people sort of
they got us into
if I were Donald Trump,
I'd be really worried about Sanders.
Seems like it may be based on
how much time he's spending on.
I'm sorry.
I think no, I would agree with Jim.
I think I think you're right.
But I think that
then leads us to this question.
So if it is Trump and DeSantis right now.
But there's a chance,
as you point out, David, that
for all of the excitement
about Ron DeSantis,
maybe that doesn't work out.
Is there anyone else you see
in the wings who could then step in
or does that
then just hand this nomination
to Donald Trump?
Yeah, well, that's
a really, really good question.
I think it easily handled
and the nomination Donald Trump.
And then he would reach out
and possibly get Nikki
Haley to be his vice
presidential candidate
for some obvious reasons.
I think she's sort of
she is
she has some upside
potential that I don't think
has been tapped into yet.
He's one of the more
I've done events with her.
And I must tell you, she's attractive.
She's interesting.
She thinks, well on our feet.
So I can see her rising
as this process goes on.
But some of the rest of them,
I just don't see
or I don't see where the rise comes from.
Jeff,
you are at CPAC for a part
of the weekend's events.
That's a pretty dark speech.
And it's interesting.
Republicans lost in 20, 18,
20, 20 and 2022.
Many Republicans would blame that guy
Donald Trump.
Yeah. He says, I am your retribution.
You need me again.
Exactly.
And look,
most presidential campaigns
have bumper sticker messages,
so I guess that fits on one.
But, boy,
if you unpack it
a little bit, like you say,
he is the cause
for a lot of the Republican Party's woes.
I mean, so the reality here
is to that crowd, to that room,
they loved it.
It was a celebration of Donald Trump
in every form.
But there was such a grievance
and so much more backward
looking sort of moods and moments
than forward looking.
But what a contrast with
with Governor Sanchez over the weekend
at the Reagan Library
and Ronald Reagan's pictures
hanging over CPAC.
Still,
his image is still
sort of mentioned a lot,
but his
conservative policies
and ideals are mentioned
very little by Donald Trump.
So that's what is fascinating this week,
I think will be
sort of seen
as a important marker
on the road to 2020
for both of those men over
the next week
are going to be in Iowa
Governor DeSantis on Friday,
Donald Trump on Monday.
What does that matter?
Because it shows
what the appetite
and room is in the Republican
primary electorate
for someone other than Donald Trump.
And Larry Hogan is also interesting
and that's a component.
If others follow his lead
and stay out of the race, a narrow field
certainly does not help Donald Trump.
And so you mentioned DeSantis.
If you look at the polling right
now, it's early.
Nobody votes for a year.
Iowa caucuses next February some time.
But but if you look back at history,
the two
guys are one guy way up at the top.
If there's a big gap, it tends to matter.
Ron DeSantis
at the Reagan Library,
Donald Trump runs
against Reagan, runs against Bush, runs
against the past,
says he's the new Republican Party.
Ron DeSantis
trying to make a point there,
no doubt who he has in mind.
There are talkers and there are doers.
You didn't see our administration
leaking like a sieve.
You didn't see a lot of drama
or palace intrigue.
What you saw was surgical precision,
exact Day after day after day.
And because we did that,
we beat the left.
Day after day after day.
It goes back to this woke mind virus
that's infected
the left
and all these other institutions.
The very end
there is the governor
making his case against the left.
But the beginning of
that was the case against Donald Trump.
He didn't mention his name.
Now, will DeSantis
do it that strongly on a debate stage?
We will see come August,
but that's what he's trying to say there.
Trump talks. I do.
And you're seeing these Republicans
use March.
I think it was Asa Hutchinson
who said yesterday for messaging
and perhaps April for
some of them is for announcing
if you're going down that road.
But that is exactly
what they're trying to do
is trying to find
a lane
for themselves that Donald Trump,
as has a Trump lane already,
they're all trying to find a lane
for themselves right now.
DeSantis talking out a very clear
one for himself.
You saw Chris Sununu over the weekend
talking about trying to get independents
and getting their support.
There's there's not a lot of support
if you look at that
got pulling outside of Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump currently.
So how are they all going
to distinguish themselves?